شارك 12 وزيرا في حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
في مؤتمر شعبي يدعو لاعاده احياء
المستوطنات في قطاع غزه واتخاذ اجراءات
لتشجيع تهجير الفلسطينيين من القطاع من
بين الوزراء المشاركين اعضاء في حزبي
ليكود الذي يراسه بنيامين نتنياهو ودعى
وزير الامن القومي تمار بنفير رئيس
الحكومه الى اتخاذ ما وصفه باجراءات شجاعه
عبر استئناف المشروع الاستيطاني في قطاع
غزه
اتوجه اليك من على هذا المنبر سيدي رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو انها مضيعه للوقت
الانتظار 19 عاما اخر لكي نعي ان علينا
استعاده مستوطنات غوش قطيف وشمال الضفه
القياده الشجاعه وظيفتها اتخاذ قرارات
شجاعه حان الوقت للعوده الى الوطن حان
الوقت للعوده الى ارض اسرائيل حان الوقت
لفرض عقوبه الاعدام على المخربين حان وقت
الانتصار في المقابل هاجم زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه يائير لابيد هذا الاجتماع لا
سما مشاركه وزراء من حزب الليكود الحاكم
فيه لابيد قال ان الحكومه وصلت الى حضيض
جديد ووصف الاجتماع بوصم عار على جنبين
نتنياهو وحزب الليكود الذي شكل يوما ما
مركز المعسكر القومي واضاف زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه ان الليكود ينجر الان بشكل
يائس وراء من وصفهم بالمتطرفين على نحو
يسبب ضررا دوليا لاسرائيل ويشكل خطرا على
احتمال اتمام صفقه التبادل اسرا
جديده